focus on one idea and make it work focus
on one business model focus on one
Revenue stream focus on one social media
Network and make it work so many times
we're focused on too many things we're
distracted and our entrepreneur ADHD
kicks in and as a result nothing happens
for all the people who are telling you
to have 13 different passive income
streams because if one goes away you
still have all those other 12. most
people who start off doing that make
zero money from all of the passive
income streams you're making ten dollars
a month four dollars a month where
instead if you could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
built to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people have got a
big message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is how
do I be on every social media platform
how do I be everywhere how do I get
started and just blow up everywhere you
don't right answers don't don't don't
try to do that
well sore
Circle but you know you're capable of
much more and you get that Push by
surround yourself with the best so today
let's learn from one of the best my
husband Evan Carmichael and learn just
focus on one idea and make it work enjoy
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much better it doesn't mean
that you can't be there you know
it doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether it's a social media
success whatever it is what you have to
figure out is how do I start to as soon
as possible get a sustainable business
for myself
so that I can quit my job if you have
one so that I can bring income in for
myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team then if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I could pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy light but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money but then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start like look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big goal and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I look at a lot of thought leaders a lot
of people have a message a lot of people
want to be speakers and authors and
coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
uh getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching
if we had those are four opportunities
in front of you right let's say so what
did I say being a speaker getting paid
to speak getting paid to do brand deals
getting paid to be an author and selling
books even selling courses your own
materials and training and Etc and
coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you can do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path that gets you out
of your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
get paid immediately while we work on
the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet you don't have a brand yet so could
it work absolutely will it pay you more
than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than
coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
I'm much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service and a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem
and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
like when is it going to come out what
year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
right how much time has gone into your
course it's like we start and stop and
start and stop because we're tackling so
many different things because you want
to do it all and you want to have income
streams coming in like crazy and there's
nothing wrong with that it's amazing but
there's a sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
we just need to focus it's all possible
your big dreams are possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus rule number two stop hiding if I
can't tell the difference between you
and all your competitors then the only
reason why I'm going to buy from you is
because you have a cheaper price you
don't want to win on being the cheapest
you're amazing you're a genius you have
Michael Jordan level talent and it's
time for the world to see it you need to
stop hiding so remember not too long ago
I was in New York and I was meeting with
uh four more mentor of mine former
mentor of mine four more former Mentor
well that's hard to say three times fast
former Mentor former Mentor former
Mentor okay got it yes
meeting with a former mentor of mine and
he was asking what my competitive
Advantage was and I said believe
say believe what is that like believe I
want people to believe I want to give
people hope I want I want people to have
hope that it's possible and show them
another way it's like hope you can't be
in the Hope business you're selling hope
what is that you're never gonna win off
a hope you can't win off of believe
that's just silly and you know a younger
version of me would have felt man I
don't know maybe he's right here's this
guy who's had so much experience and
done so many things who am I to to judge
I don't know I've never done this before
but the me who was listening to him was
like this guy just doesn't get it I'm
gonna Crush I feel I already am I
already am crutches off bullied people
stop and say hey you're the believe God
yeah that's my mission yo that's what
I'm doing every day that's what I wake
up trying to spread it's the world's
biggest problem and I'm tackling it I'm
gonna make my dent in the universe Steve
right I'm gonna go make my dent in the
universe
that's my competitive advantage
and there may be people who don't
understand it and that's okay you can't
let their limited view of the world and
and super limited view of you prevent
you from going off and doing your thing
so how do you find out what your
competitive Advantage is I'm going to
give you a three-step process that I
think will help we go through who I have
this is a super high level overview but
I think will really help I think this
concept will be life-changing I've
already seen to be life-changing but I
hope it has a big ripple effect in the
world so Step One is the who who is your
most important core value what is it
what is your single most important core
value you have one if you're a human you
have one it's positive you're here to
make a difference what is it so for me
it's believe my most important core
value is believed what is it for you if
you have to pick one single Corvette not
a list of 20 core values that you hang
up on a wall and that nobody remembers
that doesn't count one pick one stop
saying you can't get me down to one stop
trying to be perfectionist stop getting
in your own way Clarity is power what is
the one most important core value that
you have that's your who second is your
why
who I have so why now is your purpose
comes from your pain the thing that you
struggled with the most is the thing
that you want to help other people with
so I could believe in anybody right I
could believe you know I'm looking down
at the traffic down there on on the 401
the business Highway in Canada I'm
looking at the cars down there and I
could believe in every one of those
people down there every one of those
people
I love believing in entrepreneurs more
than anybody else because that's where I
struggled that was my biggest pain me
saying I quit I'm a business partner not
knowing what to do next was the was the
worst day of my life
and so I want to make it a little bit
easier for other entrepreneurs not to
struggle and feel alone as much as I did
and so whatever you struggled with the
most painful moment in your life
emotional pain not physical pain
emotional pain what was it
your purpose your why for the rest of
your life is helping people who
currently are what you used to be
helping people who currently are going
through the thing that you struggled so
much through you'll love helping people
in general humans are built to serve
you'll love it you'll love holding the
door for somebody you'll love you know
buying the grocery somebody behind you
in line you'll love random random active
kindness you'll love cuddling a cute
puppy you love all of that stuff it's
great we're built to serve we are it's
hardwired into US you'll love serving
but if you find somebody who is who you
used to be and you help them see a path
forward you represent hope to them you
give them strategies to come out of that
hole and learn from you it's going to
fill you up on a whole new level you are
built to serve and your purpose comes
from your pain that's your why who why
last one is how how is how you got out
of it
how did you get out of the hole
that wasn't some random event you
probably tried a whole bunch of things
to try to to try to learn and get better
and improve
you found the couple things that
actually worked that wasn't some random
fluke that's a teachable recipe that you
can show other people how you got out of
the hole is something that you can teach
other people so that they can climb out
of the hole as well they'll see you as
somebody who represents hope to them but
not just hope strategies you're telling
them what to do right the hope is that
is the emotional component that is
required if they don't have hope they're
not going to do anything but once you
got their their heart now you got to
lock in their brain and say well here's
how to do it here's the steps one two
three let's go
right so that's the how and for me how I
save my business that I quit on my
business partner was I modeled success I
looked at Bill Gates and how he started
Microsoft because I had a software
company and so I learned from him I
applied those strategies and I said now
my company started to grow and what have
I been doing for the past 20 years
modeling success the same thing that I
learned when I was 19 I'm still doing
now and I'm teaching it now right I'm
showcasing all these videos and
everything you learn from all these
successful people so how you got out of
it even if you're not down climbing
you're not done I'm not done believing
in myself there's still a million more
steps to go Awesome every time we take a
step you pull somebody up
every time you take another step you
pull somebody out you give back you look
back you help you assist and how you can
reach back is through the lessons that
you have learned and so you go through
the who why how process right who your
one word most important core value why
your purpose comes in your pain and then
how it becomes your passion however you
got out of the hole yourself you can
teach other people and all of those
combined becomes your competitive
advantage
so nobody can touch you nobody can touch
believing in entrepreneurs like me you
wanna you wanna do videos like I do it
awesome I don't worry about it because
at best you're going to be a junior Evan
Carmichael I want you to go do you I'm
facing forward right I'm in the present
facing forward zero times spent in the
rear view mirror right and so that
becomes your competitive Advantage you
gotta go find it also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three be a problem
solver making money is about solving
problems that's the core of business
someone has a problem you see a solution
they pay you to solve it if you're not
making money it's because you haven't
solved a big enough problem yet so let's
use my YouTube channels as an example
now we got so many YouTube channels it's
crazy
I saw a problem I saw a need right I
wanted visual content I wanted to learn
from successful entrepreneurs and I
wanted it done in a visual way I used to
read books a lot because books was the
only way that I was able to get this
information I didn't have mentors to
teach me about business right I had my
parents who were amazing who taught me
how to be a human but I didn't have any
face-to-face mentors that I can go to so
I went the books but I'm a visual
learner I'd much rather see it I get a
lot more by seeing Simon talk about a
message than by reading his book I just
do it's how I learned and I think a lot
of people are visual Learners and so
it's why I started my YouTube channel
I started showcasing successful stories
I started sharing my stories while in
the process and has been that Duality
from the beginning of saying here's
where you can learn from successful
people and here's my message as well so
DJ plus thought leader mixed together
and here we go and and we've had success
because it solves a problem because a
lot of you have the same problem my
problem is your problem you want more
success around you you want to be
surrounded by these people just like I
did and instead of you having to watch
40 hours of Simon Sina content to find
the best and mush it together I do it
for you I actually didn't want to even
have a YouTube channel I didn't want to
do this I wish you did this if one of
you did this I would just subscribe be
great be free here we go amazing it was
it didn't exist it wasn't out there so I
did it and that's the process you could
scratch your own itch you could you can
see what problems other people have but
success in business comes from solving
other people's problems you subscribe to
this channel because you like the
content because you know hopefully
hopefully like the content it adds value
to your life it solves a problem it sets
you up for the day that's why I have
this morning espresso series of five
times a week Monday to Friday set you up
for the day give you the shot of energy
motivation plus ideas to help you go off
and build your business this is the
problem that I solve what's the big
problem that you solve now there's three
different kinds of problems you can
solve I'm gonna break them down for you
right here number one is solve a big
problem for a few people you solve a big
problem this is this is where you get
into really custom consulting or super
expensive products not everybody can buy
a Ferrari right it solves a problem for
a few people who have a lot of money and
mean something to them and so they put
it into it right looking at Super
high-end Medical Treatments right it's
it's a big is it a big problem yes right
like this person might die if they don't
get the medical treatment it might be
something super rare that doesn't hit a
lot of people and so to get treatment it
often costs tons and tons and tons of
money but people are willing to pay it
they go into massive debt to pay it
because they don't want to die or they
want they don't want their family
members to die and so you're solving a
really big problem a huge problem for a
tiny group of people and you charge a
lot of money option number two is solve
a small problem for a lot of people
that's what a lot of what my content is
about right
my content for the most part is not life
or death right if you don't have access
to my videos you're not gonna die
probably right I hope not
but I hit a lot of people right I wanna
I wanna solve the world's biggest
problem I want to hit a billion people
with my content I'm trying to spread it
a message in a tiny way across a lot of
people I'm not going to meet most of you
I've got my tour coming up by the way if
anybody wants to jump in the tour Link
in the description come meet me on tour
looking forward to it
but besides that I'm probably not going
to meet most of you that's okay I'm
trying to touch people with my videos
with my books in a meaningful way but in
a small way right if I if I'm part of
your success I'm half of one percent
you're still off going off and doing the
work I I don't know most of you
personally that's amazing I'm solving a
small problem for a lot of people and
option number three is solve a big
problem for a lot of people and this is
the hardest one to do this is this is if
you solve cancer
going to help a lot of people and it's a
really really really really really
really big problem so those are your
three options you either solve a big
problem for a few people you solve a
small problem for a ton of people or you
solve a big problem for a lot of people
but at the end of the day you have to
solve problems if you're solving
problems and it's meaningful to the
people that you're selling to You're
Gonna Make Money That's The Core
Business you want to make money help
more people you want to make money
quickly help more people quickly that's
the process rule number four work hard
hard work is your ticket in no matter
where you come from what you look like
what your skills are hard work is always
the ticket in the odds might be against
you awesome now what quit on your dreams
or keep working hard how you answer that
question will change your life so I have
an agent in New York and when I first
started the agency I almost didn't get
in I didn't get in because I'm a weird
case for them my agent now he looked at
me back then and this must have been six
or seven years ago by now and he said
Evan I love your message the problem is
you're not a very good communicator and
that hurt at the beginning because I had
already done some speaking gigs I'd
already been making videos for three or
four years you know I've had hundreds if
not a thousand videos already under my
belt and here he is saying that I suck
at communicating and he said the people
that he typically works with are people
who are already in media who have tons
of experience who are great in front of
the camera they need help refining their
message he said for you I love your
message you've got a great message you
just suck at being a little communicated
like
wow
wow and so okay great well where do we
go from here and he said I'm gonna take
a flyer on you
I don't normally do this I'm going to
take a flyer on you and see where you go
and I I didn't want to waste my
opportunity I didn't even know that you
could get an agent as a as a business
person as an entrepreneur as a speaker I
mean I guess I heard of speaking houses
but an agent I thought more
entertainment or Sports not for business
so I didn't want to lose this
opportunity you know I didn't want to
regret not giving it my best and so I
said okay great tell me what I need to
do I'm the worst right now awesome I I
don't have the skills that everybody
else here has how can I get better what
do I need to do tell me and he said okay
so your first challenge is I need you to
make a bio video and I need you to tell
your story a foundation Story video
make it 20 to 40 minutes long and record
it and I'm gonna look at it and I'm
going to give you my feedback on it okay
great so I recorded it the next day and
it was in the morning and recorded it
sent it to him he gave me feedback
and then at lunch I recorded it again he
gave me feedback I recorded it again in
the evening I did it 30 to 40 times
that's a lot over over the course of
however many days you know 10 to 12 days
I guess uh I recorded the video over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over again every time you give me
feedback I do it again feedback do it
again
and I got better and I got better I know
for the course of a couple months
when I was making three videos a day
practicing sucking but just practicing
and trying to get better and listening
feedback and trying to improve I quickly
became the best case at the agency I
quickly became the number one person
from from views from subscribers from
Best Practices I copy what Evan's doing
now I'm being brought on to help them
with their clients and train some of
them and how they can get better on
YouTube and build their brand
from being the worst swimming the guy
who almost didn't get in
because the people who are joining them
one maybe had bigger egos but also we're
having a hard time finding the time to
make a video a week
and if they're not making a video a week
or having a hard time doing it and I'm
making three a day even if I suck I'm
gonna get better I'm gonna outpace just
because I'm willing to work just because
I'm putting in the effort you might not
have the skills you might not have the
talent you might not have the looks you
might not have what you think you need
to have
how does an introvert
build a huge audience and and spread a
huge message and be famous on YouTube I
don't know I mean I'm working on it join
me on my journey we'll figure it out
together
that was my agent's concern when I first
got started and I'm I'm breaking the
mold and doing things in a way that
haven't been done and you can do the
same thing
through hard work hard work doesn't
guarantee your success there's a lot of
people who work really hard and never
win a lot of people who work 12-hour
days and are doing minimum wage jobs
they're working hard and they don't win
you have to work hard and you have to
work smart but it's not one or the other
the people who were in The Agency were
working smart but we're making one video
a week
I was working less smart
but making three videos a day so I'm
gonna get better I'm gonna get smarter
I'm gonna make it faster I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you what I can do
hard work is always your ticket in and
one of the biggest problems is people
just aren't working either hard enough
or smart enough
just want it too soon and you can be
impatient and it's amazing but better
than being impatient with the results is
being impatient with yourself
most people are impatient with the
results like it's not coming fast enough
like where are my subscribers or My
Views it's not happening my first video
took me a year to get three comments and
the first come was my mom and second was
my sister and the third was some random
dude right a year to get three comments
and two of the people were my family
you're impatient with the results what
you should be is impatient with yourself
when you're not getting results when
it's not happening
audit yourself are you putting in the
work are you doing enough work are you
working smart enough are you applying
the right strategies get more frustrated
with yourself and your effort more than
that the results aren't there because if
you woke up every day and did that
equivalent of making three videos a day
when other people are making one video a
week you will eventually win it might be
slower than you'd like but it's always
slower than you'd like but you will
eventually win because hard work is
always your ticket in so what's the
process I'm going to give you three
steps to follow that I think will help
step number one is have a mission I'm
not a big believer in having 10-year
goals
um I I think to know what you think
you're capable of in a 10-year window is
ridiculous think about who you were 10
years ago there's no way that person
could predict where you are right now
not if you're growing not if you're
having any kind of success now if you've
evolved as a human the goals you had 10
years ago I'm I'm I just started my
YouTube channel 10 years ago right 29
years old 10 years ago I was just
starting my YouTube channel there's no
way I could predict where I would be
here the goals that I would set for
myself when I was 29
would be totally off compared to where
I'm at right now it's great I think you
can have a 10-year goal I think you can
hit it the problem is I think that's
small compared to what you're capable of
so instead you have a mission something
that motivates you something that drives
you something you want to work hard at
every day something so big that you will
never accomplish in your lifetime and
yet you wake up every day you want to
take another spoon from the ocean right
every day you take another Spoonful out
of the ocean you're never going to take
all the water out but you took another
Spoonful and another Spoonful and
another Spoonful so what's your mission
more important than having a 10-year
goal what is the mission that you are on
that you have to see birth into the
world because it matters because you're
built to serve because you want to have
an impact on the people around you
number two is have play bigger triggers
I'm a big believer and and play bigger
triggers which means you have things in
your environment that trigger you for
success
so the Doritos back here no I'm not
sponsored by Doritos it's a play bigger
trigger I want to eat these all day long
it's a reminder to myself that I'm
stronger than the Doritos because damn
the Doritos these pictures all mean
something to me they all mean they may
not mean anything to you but they mean
something to me
the plaques down there from my YouTube
Awards mean something the cast that you
can't really see but what I wore on my
neck for for 60 days when I broke my
neck in two spots on my first trip on my
first tour this year it means something
to me my first camera is down there too
that I use for two years all these
things it reminds me of who I am
it reminds me that I'm that I'm stronger
than I am right now in the moment that
I'm capable of great things that I
finished my tour with a broken neck in
two spots and still went to another 30
Days on the Road that's crazy right it's
it's hard to imagine and I did that
and so that's that's how I remind myself
that I did that I had the I have the
cast there and so whatever makes you
feel bold whatever makes you feel
confident whatever makes you feel alive
put it in your environment your physical
environment your actual office where
you're doing the work but also your
virtual environment what's on the
background of your cell phone what's on
the background of your desktop right
what do you have you're looking at it
multiple times a day does it fill you up
so having to play bigger trigger for
yourself what do you need to have in
your environment because you only set it
up once right I only set this up once I
only put this here once and every day I
walk in and it triggers me for Success
every single day and set number three is
past the pillow test so I have a pillow
test where if you have a pillow right
before you hit the bed before you hit
your pillow before don't hit the pillow
before you hit your head on the pillow
if you're very angry you can hit the
pillow before you hit your hand on the
pillow ask yourself are you proud of the
effort that you put in tonight that's
the pillow test if you woke up every day
and you are proud of the effort even if
you didn't get the results but you are
proud of the effort that you put in that
today I did something that made me feel
proud that was outside my comfort zone
that I wanted to quit but I kept going
regardless and I did another take
another video even though it didn't get
the result I'm proud of what I did today
if you woke up every day and did that
and you're proud of your effort you're
gonna create amazing things
most people aren't part of their effort
most people will do just enough just
enough that what the client wants or
just enough of what you think your your
audience wants your customers want or
just just enough you do just enough
to do more just enough
tie yourself Worth to the effort you're
putting in instead of the results
ask yourself tonight
are you proud of the effort that you put
in I'm proud of the effort I'm putting
in on this video do I get a result do
you love it maybe yes maybe no maybe
it's the worst video of all time for you
that's not me I need to get better I'm
working on it every single day I'm
trying but I'm proud of the effort that
I'm putting I'm trying I'm trying and if
you woke up every day and you were
trying your hardest chasing down the
goals and the life that you want you're
gonna get it
you're gonna get it because you're
unstoppable but only if you're putting
in your maximum effort every day and you
pass the pillow test rule number five
the last one before our very special
bonus clip belief what's the difference
between you and Jack Ma you both have
crazy dreams you both started with the
odds stacked against you you both
started with very little resources so
what's the difference the difference is
that Jack kept believing in his dreams
and his ideas when most people quit and
give up so I actually think you should
be on a mission for life I'm not a big
believer in in five year goals or ten
year goals I think they can help but I
think if you have a five or ten year
goal you're actually thinking small
because you can't predict where you're
going to be in five or ten years just
like the person you were five or ten
years ago could not have designed the
life for where you're at right now not
if you're growing because the world's
changing too quickly and you're growing
and evolving so the ideas and goals that
you had five years ago may not even be
relevant anymore but the mission stays
the same my mission is belief right your
purpose comes from your pain so my my
mission is believe I want to support
entrepreneurs uh because I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur and I think it's
the world's biggest problem I think the
world's biggest problem is people don't
believe in themselves enough
I think any other problem that you come
up with should have already been solved
by now but the person who could solve
that cancer you know the woman who
should have solved cancer is an account
manager at McDonald's
because she never won she never tried
going to medical school or two she did
but she didn't believe in herself enough
to chase it down because everybody
around there is telling her that she's
crazy you should be crazy you're doing
something that's never been done before
you're on a mission right and so no
matter how many people I touch with with
all of my content all my channels every
video that I'm making every speaking gig
every city that I go to no matter how
many people I touch it's not going to be
enough
I think that's great I think you should
have a mission so big that you're never
going to actually accomplish it I think
of Ted Turner's father who when he made
a certain amount of money became a
millionaire or whatever the number was
he killed himself because he hit his
goal and and hitting your goal is
actually sad
and so Ted Turner decided that I'm going
to set a goal so big that I could never
hit it and that's way more where I'm
aligned I think you should have a
mission something so big that you can
never hit it some people think of that
as well it's two it's too big and so why
even try
and I think of that that starfish
example of the kids at the beach with
the starfish and he there's like a
million starfish on the beach and she's
throwing the starfish back in the water
so they can live and the guy walks by
and says
what are you doing you can't save all
the starfish and she says I know but I
can save that one and this one and that
one right and so each person that you
helped each step you take is is
beneficial it's helpful you never want
to actually hit the goal but you wake up
every day working your face off to try
to hit the goal right to hit that
mission and so that's belief for me and
I desperately hope that you find it for
you so how do you keep believing your
dreams I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help number one is make big decisions
with your heart so big decisions with
the heart small ones with the head at
the beginning when you're trying to
decide what to do your head and your
heart often will will fight they'll
conflict they won't be aligned because
your head only understands a world that
currently exists it's safe it's
practical it's logical it knows what
currently exists where your heart can
create something brand new your heart
can imagine something that's never
existed before and so they Clash at the
beginning right your heart wants to go
do this thing but you don't know how
it's going to work out because it
doesn't make sense because nobody's done
it before and especially someone who
looks like you with your resources and
your education your background and your
connection in your financial situation
nobody like you has ever done it before
that's what your head's saying and so
this is big fight
you need to take control of the
situation you need to get them aligned
by saying this is what I'm doing right
big decisions with the heart
and then your head's saying oh
he's serious she's serious okay I better
help because I don't want to die
and now your head starts working with
you now your head starts helping you
figure out how to actually go off and
accomplish it you're using your thinking
side to help you accomplish your mission
but at the very beginning it doesn't
make sense until they'll fight so the
big decisions with the heart and then
the small ones with your head to help
you figure out how to actually do it
step number two is daily momentum the
biggest thing that you are missing is
momentum you're a genius you have
Michael Jordan level Talent you can save
the world you've got a big ambitious
crazy mission that you're on I love it
it's amazing that's why you're here
that's why you're an entrepreneur let's
go right
pretty easily about entrepreneurship the
problem is you don't have momentum
there's no momentum nothing's happening
enough on a daily basis and so you need
daily momentum it doesn't matter that
you watch one video like this and then
you're on fire the rest of the day it
has to be every day every single day you
have to build momentum to your business
too many entrepreneurs they start and
they stop and they start and they stop
and they're starting to stop they never
get anywhere
because they're too busy starting and
stopping and and then you know what
where's my you didn't create the
momentum that's what's missing every
single day do the thing put it into your
morning routine that makes you feel bold
alive Unstoppable confident and then go
out and create momentum that is your
duty your responsibility your must every
single day create momentum and then step
number three is ask yourself what would
the most bold version of you do but with
the most bold version of you dude just
ask that question here's your mission
here's what you're trying to accomplish
you're looking at your calendar you're
looking at what you want to accomplish
but with the most bold just eliminate
any insecurities eliminate fears
eliminate judgment eliminate the toxic
people for your life just for this
magical you know 18 seconds
and ask yourself what would the most
bold version of me do and then see what
comes back
and then chances are that's the actual
thing that you should be doing because
you know what you do bold things
most people either have no idea who they
are and what they want or they do but
they don't have the courage and
confidence to chase it down if you don't
know who you are and what you want then
that needs to be your immediate priority
that's the single most important
exercise that you can do right now if
you know what you want but you're not
chasing after it having more confidence
in who you are will give you the courage
to chase it down either way I'm gonna
give you the answers in this video so
when I first started making videos
I sucked you can go back you can watch
the first one it was April 2009 over 10
years ago I sucked I was nervous I was
shy I was trying to memorize lines I was
sitting down I was in a suit I was
sweating I sucked it was brutal
and making videos
isn't a logical choice for someone like
me I was introverted I still am I was
afraid of being in front of the camera
I'm looking into the lens and the red
light went on and I went blank I was
trying to memorize my lines just on
paper if you saw me and you said what I
was good at and then put me in in a
situation where I'm making videos that
don't do that that's not for you here's
the thing I liked it
I wasn't good at it but I liked it and
when you like something with enough
effort enough practice most things you
can be great at it
now I'm still on my journey I still have
a long way to go there's still people I
look up to guys like Gary who are
crushing it and say I still have my
journey to get better on but I'm a lot
better than I was when I started and now
I'm off doing keynote speeches and I'm
getting flown out and getting paid to
speak in front of audiences and I'm
growing a Channel with two million
subscribers and then these sub channels
on top of them it's crazy because I was
doing a thing that on paper I wasn't
supposed to be good at but I just loved
it and that's where the self-awareness
piece comes in
because you will get an idea to go off
and try something but you'll judge the
idea and you'll say I can't do this
because I don't have X and Y and Z and
I'm not good enough and tall enough and
smart enough for whatever enough right
I'm not enough
and then you play small for life and you
have uncertainty and you're walking on
quicksand and you end up being pulled
into making somebody else's dreams come
true instead of you actually chasing
your own version of your life down
because you're thinking about all the
reasons why you're not going to win
instead of the eight while you will so
take it from me a guy who's introverted
afraid of camera shy
doesn't like talking to people
if I can get here so can you on your
dreams now I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I know will help
it's a topic of my new book called build
to serve if you guys want to get the
copy built to serve we'll link it up
here go get it pre-orders right now it's
an amazing book you have to get it I'll
see you there okay so we're gonna go
through a three-step process who why how
who this is how you just this is how you
develop your self-awareness it starts
with who who is your one word most
important core value so you think about
all the things that made you come alive
all the people that you love the books
you read the music you listen to what's
the common theme it's not random the
reason why you love that band and love
that song and love that movie and love
that teacher from grade four French is
that because she taught you French all
of those things that you love are
connected there's a theme between them
that's your job to figure it out you
have a single most important core value
that strings all the things that you
love together and when you find out what
that is it allows you to create a better
life going forward with intention with
action so for me it's believe right my
parents here on the wall taught me I'm
Evan because Shirley Carmichael I can do
anything that I believe I can
my favorite teachers growing up are the
ones who believed in me my favorite
movie of all time is seabiscuits about
this horse that's too small a jockey
that's too big a an owner that's
bankrupt and they all find each other
it's a it's a story of belief and so
what do I make what's the content on my
channels it's always positive it's
always inspirational it's always believe
my channel could probably be bigger if I
was doing negative content the stupidest
things that this person said or look at
the fight between him and him and why
right my channel would actually grow
faster but I want to be proud of the
work I'm doing I want to have believe be
at the core of everything that I'm
making this video it's always my
intention whether I succeed or not
whether you actually feel believe or not
I hope you do because that's what I'm
trying to put out but if you don't
that's my fault but it's always the
intention right so when you figure out
what your most important core value is
it allows you to build a much more
intentional life that you are starting
to design instead of falling what other
people want you to do step number two is
your why so who why how two is your why
your why is your purpose your purpose
comes from your pain purpose from pain
your purpose comes from your pain
whatever you struggled with the most as
a as a human where you felt the lowest
you felt worthless you felt like you
added no value that you were just the
lowest possible human alive right
whenever you felt the worst your purpose
is to help other people who are
currently going through that
and you may not be totally through you
might still be struggling you might
still be on your journey that's okay
you're further ahead than you used to be
you're further ahead than you were a
year ago or two years ago or five years
ago or ten years ago or whenever this
thing happened to you the most emotional
pain that you felt you're further ahead
and you right now can go back and talk
to who you used to be and give that
person advice in a way that only you
could in a way that I couldn't reach
like you can reach who you were five
years ago in a way that I couldn't reach
today
and and Tony Robbins couldn't reach him
garyvee couldn't reach you can reach
them in a way that nobody else can reach
that's your purpose because humans have
built to serve that same of my book
built to serve humans are built to serve
but you can serve in a lot of different
ways
just doing acts of kindness good deeds
will make you feel good it's wired into
us right helping others has the same
impact on your brain as food and sex it
hits the same spot so you want to serve
you want to help
but how do you help
and so when you can do some kind of act
of kindness a good deed hold the door
for somebody awesome makes you feel good
but what will take you up to a whole
other level is helping people who
currently are what you used to be and
there's lots of people the person who
you used to be there are lots of people
who currently are that your purpose
comes from your pain the idea is not to
live in the pain and stay in the pain
and wallow in the pain you've come
through it at least partly you use that
as strength to now go and help countless
other people because now you're on a
mission and then we get to step number
three which is our house so who why how
how is how did you get out of the hole
that you were in what did you struggle
with what did you suffer with so my who
is believed my why is helping
entrepreneurs because I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur and then how I
got out of it how did I struggle so much
as an entrepreneur and then get out of
the hole it was through Modern success
my software company was really
struggling I was making 300 a month and
I I felt embarrassed and ashamed as a
human that I've added no value to the
world
I studied Bill Gates and how he started
his software company I modeled that
success and I started to have success in
my company modern success saved my
company
and save my self-worth
and so what have I done now for the past
20 years is teach people how to model
success what's the point of that why why
have this video here why I have this
channel I'm trying to teach you what
garyvee knows what I know what all the
people on my channel have to share so
that you can model success and get on
your path faster right that's the goal
and so that's my how my how then became
a recipe for other people that for the
past 20 years it's all I've been doing
same thing for you however you got out
of the hole that you were in and again
you may not be all the way out that's
okay you're further ahead than you used
to be how did you do it what did you do
to get out was it was it modern success
was it was it meditation was it prayer
was it drinking water every day like
what did you do to get out of it
you can teach that that wasn't random
there's a lot of people who don't know
what to do Who currently are facing the
issues that you used to face they're
stuck
and you represent hope
because you made it out you're further
along and whatever you did to get there
you can now teach other people how to do
the same thing and that will fill you up
for life you who your why your how from
the book built to serve that's how you
have self-awareness
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue typically I
will see you there you need to mix what
you love with what there's a demand for
okay if you love it but there's no
demand you have a hobby and that can
fill your soul but it's a hobby if
you're just chasing what's hot but you
have no interest in it you're never
gonna win